how does simple interest would you
remember what the formula was good so we
use this or or T
that's right cuz that's about time we
use this to calculate interest what was
the point of calculating interesting why
does it just exist
what is it yes money what kind of money
is it it's extra money money on top of
money that you paid right usually for
example if you get a loan right right
you borrow some money and then you have
to pay extra for the fact that they
they're letting you use their money for
little walk or vice versa right so you
might take a loan of like five point
five thousand dollars design that and
then they tried you some interest on and
that's the way simple interest worked
okay now let's just give an example of
that okay five thousand dollars
if that's our principal principal five
thousand dollars okay let's make up an
interest rate what are we in say
something like six or seven percent now
just suppose we stuck that money in the
bank and put it in for I don't know
let's say a long time maybe thirty years
that is it's a long time okay now what
would that be equal to let's just
quickly work it out because we've used
this formula to death by you know right
we say I equals okay we gonna get some
some pieces together here five thousand
fine
now the rate right you don't put it in
as a percentage what do you put in is
that as a decimal
right a fraction I suppose would give
you the same thing right well what's the
decimal in this case zero point
well done six and of course your last
piece is how long it stays in there
which in this case thirty years a long
time okay now let's see how my
arithmetic skills are I think this is
zero point no that's one point eight I
think this is gonna be nine thousand so
I want to check that out
how's that yeah
it's 9,000 I figure okay oh I should
have done a little more than a thousand
plus a lot oh well now there you go
that's a lot of money by the way that's
mark how much the money's worth what
that's just the interest just the
interest so you started with this and so
if I'm putting together that'd be
$14,000 okay but here's the thing that
you guys know that if I was sitting if I
took that money out okay now you've got
all this extra money right each year
it's just been getting the same amount
added on five thousand times
oh six how much is it getting each year
thirty years
I got nine thousand dollars interest in
total how much is being added on every
single year each individual is $300 $300
when he threw him into the next few do
next
okay but here's the thing if I hold that
money out off the same 15 years right
it wouldn't be 5,000 more it would have
burned right and then I couldn't stuck
in some other Bank maybe it would have
been you know after after 10 years maybe
5,000 plus those 10 months of 300 right
so after 10 years I'd be able to take
that $5,000
the extra interest that had 8 grand and
then I could put that in a bank right
and in earn more interest than my
original 5000 does that makes sense
it's gonna be worth more so if I put in
another Bank even it's the same interest
rate it's actually gonna earn more
because the principal is bigger now this
principle works all the time you don't
have to wait 10 years you can wait like
one year or a day even right average
everyday that it's in there the money's
getting bigger right it shouldn't be
paid the same amount over and over again
this amount interest should be getting
bigger as well okay so that's why we
introduced said your compound interest
I'll show you how it works underneath
your subheading you might like to call
it real interest because in banks
investments in that going to be there
all done by compound interest almost no
one uses simple interest because simple
interest is a bit a ripoff right your
money just sits there and it gets the
same man it just pervert over again
but compound interest they have interest
compounds on itself it gets its bigger
and bigger and bigger
that's why it's called compound interest
so let's do an example let's start with
that $5,000 again and we'll do it on a
year-to-year basis so see what happens
to this figure okay
I'm gonna rub this off because let's
just think about at the end thirty years
and I think we said five thousand plus
nine thousand that's fourteen so that's
what happens thirty years simple
interest what happens if we compound it
here's what I mean what we do is every
single year we work out how much
interest again okay every single year
right so we would do this is well let's
think about how this works normally okay
if I go one year six percent interest
the first year how much interest am I
going to make well we just worked this
out right it's five thousand times zero
point zero sixth is the rate times well
just one year
there's my end okay now think we just
discussed that's $300 is that okay okay
so $300 so I need to introduce a bit
more um language here so that I can talk
about these and distinguish them okay so
I'm gonna call this number here p0 pay
for principal and zero for this is where
I'm starting this is my starting point
after no times past zero time is past
that's when I started okay so if I write
p1 what's the principal after one year
okay South five thousand we got this
much interest so what's what am I gonna
have their problem okay ah but now I'm
gonna work out interest again and my
principal is bigger now okay so if I
work out the interest on this
interests which is less you there's my
new principal times the same rate times
another year now I don't know what that
is that's a bit of a hot number to work
with so can someone on the calculator
tell me what that's equal to yeah what
do we got three hundred in how much is
that exact or okay great now have a look
the principal from here to here was
bigger right the principal grew in size
so therefore the interest also grew in
size wait but we got paid an extra three
hundred at the end of the first year but
now we get paid more right all right
let's do it again let's see what happens
so now I've got p2 after two years I
started fifty three hundred and I add on
318 so now how much do I have five six
one eight okay I'm gonna do it again but
this is my new principal okay so I'll go
interest equals hmm five six one eight
right I'll multiply by 0.06
again and then I do one more year
okay these numbers are getting hard for
me so what's up how can I tell us how
much against any three eight are there
any numbers after that that's it okay
great
sir that's the interest I get paid
during the third year so at the end of
three years I should have this amount
plus this interest okay let's see what
is that five nine five five is that
right
someone just verify that movie I know
but yeah that's okay all right so I'm
adding how much I started with at the
start of the second year and then how
much interest I got in that second year
this is at the end the guy just lost
brain cells um now